this is your one and only spoiler
warning
if you don't want spoilers for one
division and speculations of
possible major upheavals for the mcu
going forward
then i suggest you run out of here so
fast that it makes it seem like the rest
of us are standing still
i would apologize for the fact that that
opening joke basically gave away the
spoiler except i told you even before
that so
if you guys spoiled by that it's your
own dang fault okay wanda vision episode
five
big stuff to talk about i did my review
over in the break room of geeks you
should be subscribed to that if you're
not
and uh i mentioned there that i was
gonna have to do a whole other
video on the fact
that evan peters's
version of quicksilver from the x-men
movies turns up
yeah so we don't know what this means
yet
i'm gonna talk through my thought
process and what i think it might mean
and also
give i was going to say give the odds
i'm not going to be that
statistical about it but i'm going to
talk about what i consider to be more or
less likely
let's start with the baseline something
that i would have considered
this to be in the time before
interconnected cinematic universes in
the time before the mcu
i would have said this is a fun gag
don't read into it that's definitely not
going to be the case here
because kevin feige and the people
behind the mcu at this point
they seem to have a pretty good grasp
and understanding of their audience
and they should know and if they don't
shame on them but they should be well
aware
that when this happened it was going to
explode
theory forums for the mcu and you cannot
make those kinds of rabbit fans
go berserk and
then go oh it was just a gag don't worry
about it
they they will not let you get away with
that and i
think the mcu folks understand that so
that's definitely not going to happen
that having been said i do not believe
that this
marks a full and proper uh
introduction and amalgamation of
the fox x-men films into the mcu
it's possible and i'll talk about some
of the ins and outs about
how that might happen but i still don't
think it's likely and i'll also talk
about that
so first off we actually don't even know
a ton about
how this is going to fit into one
division because it happens at the end
of the episode
maybe we'll find out more next week but
one thing that we do get acknowledged
right off the bat because we have darcy
watching a tv monitor and sees him show
up she asked the question
did wanda recast pietro
which means that this is not a matter of
the universe has been retconned and now
all of a sudden
this is always who her brother was it's
been acknowledged in universe
that's not who it's supposed to be so
the deviation is out in the open
and is understood by those who are
seeing it
so that is actually fairly important
because
it eliminates the possibility that they
just decided we'd rather have this
version of quicksilver not that i
thought they ever would have done that
but
that's not even a possibility so
let me start with some of the reasons
why i think
that we're probably not going to see a
full scale
complete integration of the
fox x-men movies into the mcu
the first is a big chunk of the most
iconic characters and actors from that
basically got retired i mean who was the
face of x-men
it was hugh jackman it was wolverine
and wolverine was very definitively put
to bed
in logan as was professor x for that
matter
and even if you could get patrick
stewart and or hugh jackman back for
another film
you'd probably only get them for that
one disney and marvel are going to want
to get multiple films out of whoever
they get in
to be their x-men so you need to
lose any and all hope of having hugh
jackman return as wolverine
or patrick stewart return as professor
xavier and honestly that's a good thing
anyway because to find a way to bring
them back
i think would cheapen some of the impact
of logan so
i think that's that's for the best
anyways
now of course you probably would realize
well
hold on a second evan peters is
quicksilver wasn't
really involved in the x-men movies
where
wolverine and that version of charles
xavier were central
no he was more of the prequel ones the
ones that had michael fassbender and
james
mcavoy and you'd be right and they're
certainly more viable to bring back
than certainly jackman or ian mckellen
or patrick stewart
would be but there's still some problems
here
from a completely business standpoint
it doesn't make sense to bring them in
because
what was the last well-received x-men
movie
well it was logan but we've already
discounted that
that was putting those characters to bed
and the rest of the x-men didn't appear
in it so forget that
what was it before then it was probably
x-men days of future past
though like even that one i feel like
kind of has i feel like time hasn't been
kind to that one
i boy interesting choice of words i
still kind of like it as a film
uh issues with the director
notwithstanding
but what came about after that
apocalypse dark phoenix
new mutants these
are not good for the x-men brand and
x-men collectively as a franchise as a
team
haven't really had a big hit in quite a
while
is it in disney in the mcu's interest
to pick up the baton of a universe that
audiences were very clearly
done with and were over and had lost
interest in
that's like starting at a deficit so
my inclination is that they're not going
to do that either
but they're still probably going to do
something because they've
brought in very specifically the
quicksilver from
the other x-men films
oh uh and somebody's gonna bring up
deadpool look i still anticipate that
deadpool is going to be kept
in his own bubble he's going to make
meta reference jokes
he's going to reference the merger the
buyout and all and the new continuities
and all these things
he will not get integrated into the mcu
properly
and as a meta character he doesn't have
to be
so that's my take on deadpool forget him
for right now
so the question now becomes well
what are they going to do because
they've opened the door now
well the big thing to take into account
is the upcoming doctor strange 2
the multiverse of madness or multiverses
the multiverse multiverse
of madness just that title alone
has already opened up a lot of doors and
it would be viable to
establish the x-men
films that fox made as an alternate
universe as a multi because like you
continuity wise you can't make them fit
in the mcu they don't fit they can't
they they too much went on in both
universes that
there would have been crossover and
there wasn't so
having it be another universe is
certainly a viable option
brings us the question of how this
version
of quicksilver ended up here but you
know at this point they have
amped up wanda's powers so exceptionally
maybe she unconsciously
pulled him from another dimension from
an alternate universe
or maybe if there is in fact someone
else involved
behind the scenes and it's not all
wanda's making which there's pretty good
indications that that is the case
i know there's a lot of fan theory about
it being uh
ag the harkness or dormammu
or mephisto like for my purses it
doesn't matter who it is
but if there is someone else still if
not pulling the stream
strings at least manipulating and
needling and nudging wanda in certain
directions
they could be responsible for bringing
in quicksilver
and in fact that would almost kind of
make more sense since wand is
absolutely stunned to see him and flat
out
says when the doorbell rings and he's
outside it that wasn't
me i didn't do that so i think the
possibility that he
has been pulled out of wherever he came
from and placed here by someone
other than wanda that feels like a good
uh
likelihood but again don't know who that
is don't know how
and obviously now that he's here he
appears to have been integrated into
uh west view the same as everybody else
who's there that might be wanda's doing
it's hard to
know at this point but
establishing the x-men film
franchise as an alternate universe
papers over a lot of holes
and if they happen to find
or have any other actors from that
franchise
who is willing to come over and they
think they have a way to do it
maybe we'll see that whatever brought
over
quicksilver will bring over others i'm
not gonna hold my breath
for that i my gut
instinct is that the extent to which
we're gonna get multiverse
madness with doctor strange is going to
be
glimpses visions maybe they'll even
bring some of the actors in to
give us that but again
integrating them into the mcu actually
bringing
them in it
makes things more complicated and it
just brings a lot of baggage
that wouldn't be there if disney just
opted to start with a clean
slate there could be a reason to
keep quicksilver around regardless
because wanda is lacking that
relationship
in many ways pietro was a missed
opportunity in terms of a character that
we just didn't get to spend a lot of
time with there could have been more
done with him and this is an interesting
kind of a big ip flex
style to have sort of make up for that
lost opportunity potentially but even if
we
do end up integrating more uh
characters in from the
fox x-men i don't expect a ton of that
to happen
later in the one division franchise
um other than to possibly establish that
they're out there i don't expect anymore
to get pulled over because
the more they do that in a tv show the
harder it's going to be
to have it make sense come the movies
because
unless disney makes the
bold and maybe not a completely
unfounded decision
to have the x-men be a disney plus
property
and actually not have them in the movies
unless they're doing that
which honestly is not the worst idea in
the world
but unless they do that they are going
to ultimately have to
introduce the x-men in the movies in a
way that
does not require the watching and the
understanding of one division and i know
that's really hard for fans who are
hardcore into the stuff and are watching
all the shows and keep track of
everything
and have a conspiracy board tracking all
of the continuities and everything like
most audiences don't take in
all of it and again
disney and the mcu and marvel they
seem to have understood this very well
up to this point
that you cannot put vital plot points
into one medium that is going to be
viewed less
than your primary medium and have it try
and pay off there because
way more money is in the movies way more
people watch the movies
you cannot make the movies understanding
them dependent on the tv shows
you are kneecapping the movies and the
movies make too much money to ever do
that
even now even in the time of covid where
it's like well everybody's home and
watching streaming yeah but not
everybody's watching disney plus
so broadly speaking at this point i'm
kind of anticipating
one of two outcomes coming off the back
of juan division
either either
this version of quicksilver is
going to be sent back where he came from
by the end of this or possibly just die
i hope not that
that would feel like a real retread um
either that or he sticks around but
no other x-men characters get pulled
through at least not yet and even if
that
does happen it i figure it's going to be
extremely selective
and honestly i very much doubt that they
will do it
in anything outside of a hey
look at the scope of the multiverse kind
of way
because again if they are ever going to
have the x-men
in this main universe in the mcu
[Music]
then they need a more or less clean
slate
in order to do that and it is the
opposite of a clean slate
to bring in characters from the fox ones
i wouldn't have expected them to do even
what they did here like i said it's bold
it's uh it's a heck of a move
and as excited as it made me like i
cheered and punched the air i was like
what
i lost it i just hope that they
understand
there is a limit to how far they can
push this before
it starts to crack
the foundation that they've built
because something like one division is a
good outlet for these sorts of things
and multiverse of madness is right there
in the title you should expect
you should expect multiple universes and
insanity so okay
drop some stuff there if you feel so
inclined but
i do not think
that we're going to see the fox versions
of mystique
magneto professor x either version of
any of them definitely not wolverine
or really any of them i don't think
we're going to see them
pulled in and integrated into the main
mcu
again with the asterisks unless the
x-men
become a disney plus franchise as
opposed to a film franchise
which i don't think they do because
x-men is kind of a big name
it's a movie marquee kind of name
but if they did it that way honestly
kind of all bets are off because
as is clear with one division already
you can get away with a lot
in the format where you can be fairly
certain your most devoted fans are
coming to you
so that's my rambling thoughts about
where things might go or kind of a
little bit more emphasis on what i don't
think they're going to do
what do you think about what's going on
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it like share subscribe
i have a patreon that is what pays my
bills
keeps this entire operation up and
running any amount you are able to
contribute
is greatly appreciated and there are
rewards at every tier
but you also don't have to the likes the
shares and the subscribes they help me
out as well
and at the end of the day you're the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign